hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Astra near so
apparently I don't know when this
happened but it just suddenly decided
that the printer wanted to work and I
have the necessary stuff for it no I do
not oh oh oh yes
that's awesome one seat one seat for
what one seat for who I don't know but
apparently this is able to be utilized
now so I need to go out and get this
sort of stuff the only problem is I
don't have a lot of compound and
compound seems to be the one thing that
I need a lot of and I don't know I don't
know if it's just lying around or
anything but I don't have enough oxygen
to be able to go down into the caves
just yet so now I'm in a sprint a mad
sprint Oh oxygen perfect okay so now I'm
just gonna be in a mad sprint to be able
to get the necessary materials that I
need and also explore a little bit
farther out in the landscape I don't
know why oxygen is just sitting in giant
blue puddles here but that's kind of
cool inconvenient what is that
Oh what is that what is that what is
that San Tornado Zetas haboob oh god no
that's so awesome oh no Matt Damon help
me Oh what the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's so
cool
also I oh my god oh oh my oh my god oh
my god ah oh my god okay I'm out of here
I got to get back ah [ __ ] my head oh oh
oh oh my god I'm dead I just died well
that's [ __ ] deadly don't destroy my
face oh no I like this face don't do
that that's so awesome and terrifying
what the [ __ ] that's so cool that can
just happen at any time what happens if
I'm way out in the distance do I have to
try to find shelter and do I have to
just immediately start digging in the
ground so rock doesn't break my brain
open Oh
cool how long does it last long am I
gonna be sitting here well I guess it's
I just gotta wait it out I'm not gonna
go out that mess oh I think it might be
passing over yeah yeah that is nuts
that's nuts
that's just bonkers and they used up all
of my oxygen oh I lost all my materials
oh there's my dead body
well good thing we got infinite cloning
devices up it's so cool I did not make
it far I did not do that oh my god what
if what if there's just a body there
what if I literally am a reproduce clone
oh my god there no no well that didn't
help me but yeah yeah there is a body
that is that is a body that is a body I
am a different person than that was oh
my god they just vanished
oh darling I'm out of oxygen oh god no
what are the implications of that I'm
another clone am I even human what does
that mean what am I do I even want to
know are there some questions that what
is that what the [ __ ] is that is that a
planet the [ __ ] okay all right then
Wow I am so confused so the other thing
that I've noticed is almost nothing
needs organic so there must be something
else that I could make that would be
able to do what I needed to do but for
right now I'm gonna go in the direction
that I've built this exploration because
that seems to be the most readily
available for me to do but I need to do
and I need to find a lot more resin I
there was a deposit or resin around here
somewhere I mean I'm sure that I could
just dig in the ground and probably find
some stuff but I don't have enough power
to do that and dig willy-nilly I don't
have enough oxygen just to be able to go
anywhere I want to was that that oxygen
fountain that might be an oxygen
fountain I'm not 100% sure about that
but if that's what it is
Oh resin hello I'll take all of you that
is so much resident gas please thank you
has it got to be night literally all the
time but if that's an oxygen fountain
which I'm gonna need like immediately
because I'm running out of oxygen again
that is going to be
cool all that is cool gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme
get a thank you god damn it no power but
I need the oxygen god I am in trouble
it's a little bit uh man I haven't even
had enough to fill up another batch of
oxygen I've just had enough to fill up
my bar right now there's got to be some
power around here somewhere
and I had no idea that there were like
risks of death like that no wonder there
are so many crashed ships around here
and no there's probably a lot of bodies
buried underneath this place ah there's
a power font
okay so power right there then go back
for the oxygen come on come on come on
give me him yah yah yah yah yah yah oh
yah yah yah yah gimme gimme
thoth don't look at me I'm being an
idiot right now okay so I go back and I
get the oxygen because I'm almost have
that I probably need to dump this and
dump this because I can get organic
stuff literally anywhere but what I need
right now is oxygen please please give
me give me give me give me
oh yah yah yah yah oh no it's not enough
Oh God is not enough well that was a
wasted opportunity but at least I got
some resin and I'll be able to get some
resin on the way back and that should be
everything that I actually needed to get
while I was out here got it got it got
it get it okay that's pretty full uh do
I need some compound yes maybe maybe
maybe baby what I'll do is I'll drop a
power right here
I bring the compound back because I need
two of these [ __ ] running out of
oxygen this is bad [ __ ] god damn it
are you [ __ ] kidding me come on come
on there we go go go go [ __ ] are you
kidding me yeah oh I gotta make it to
the oxygen uh I'm about soft Kate
released I got resin
okay there we got it okay so that was
good and dangerous and deadly and I
shouldn't have done that but I did it
anyway okay so I got a lot of resin
what else can I make with resin I've got
comp what the [ __ ] was that dude why
what would that come from I didn't have
this I I wish full up on stuff I'll put
you right there for now hold on
I'm I was very confused by the titanium
copper I can make a beacon but I don't
need that solar power I could make
another one of those that would be kind
of nice
it'd just be kinda nice to have that on
my back at all time so that I get double
the power whenever I need it and then
I'd need less power in general so take
this compound put it there again that
away so that is something huh boy
alright so I need to go find stuff to
apply more research to be able to Bay
and make more designs and I'm pretty
sure that I would only be able to get
the research materials out of the wrecks
around the area and I would like to go
that way I want to go that way but I
don't I haven't I haven't built up my
stuff to go in that direction yet I'm
gonna build a storage container because
I think I would actually kind of like
that because if I can go out and get a
bunch of material then keep it in
storage then I should have more than
enough and I don't have a way to do that
oh oh god dammit I'm so good at lifting
things with my brain oh man
it's just really interesting the way
that everything is constantly looking at
me like these are always pointed in the
direction that I am like just the level
of technology here is kind of amazing
okay so how do i oh yeah well that's
handy that all right so I'm gonna build
this out a bit more true buddy be doop
boop boop you think that I would be able
to make some sort of oxygen creation
device but I guess this is just a
standard limitation on what this is what
we do I think that might have been the
last of my resin yes it was okay so I'm
out of resin but this gives me a bit
more flexibility to be able to go
farther out um I went that way I'm gonna
go the opposite direction this time and
try to go over there we'll just touch up
my oxygen and here we go let's hope I
find some oxygen cuz if I don't I'm
going to be Jo duck dude look good to do
diddly did to do what is that over there
I think it's power but I don't need that
need oxygen does anybody want to give me
some oxygen out here I
alone and what the [ __ ] is that what's
with the giant yellow bricks whoa what
is this another cave oh boy Oh oxygen in
there
ooh and something else in there I don't
know if that is but I'm about to find
out oh yay okay good yeah that's
concerning
Oh oh my god oh no oh no oh no hey okay
okay that is that is a hundred percent -
why the [ __ ] was that
seriously the [ __ ] was that I have no
idea okay going down here ow my ass I
also want to mention I I don't think
I've talked about this whoa aluminum
[ __ ]
oh cool I need a smelter to be able to
do this but that's good so I want to
mention um I really like the way that
there is no user interface in this game
I it was it was almost I didn't even
notice it at first but there literally
is no interface anywhere here it's not
apparent because oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
hydrazine need you oh [ __ ] I have too
much oxygen so what I can do is I will
leave some behind because I don't need
that much but let me take the hydrazine
because I do need fuel I'm assuming I do
anyway and then there's a whole bunch of
other stuff oh my god this terrifying oh
no this is this is horrifying this is
horrible oh my god I don't want to go
down here there's got to be a way I can
make like a jet pack or something
because Oh malachite what is malachite I
don't know but I'll take it put it in
storage if I don't need it I just got to
make sure that I can actually get out of
here I need a full stack ah [ __ ] okay
stop going that way why was it pulling
me in that was [ __ ] weird okay either
way I'm outta here baby
try not to fall down deeper in this cave
of death I'm really hoping the other
aren't secretly alien life-forms
literally uh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
that the [ __ ] is that the [ __ ] is that
I'll grab you but I'm not happy about oh
that is horrifying okay not the only
problem is I can't jump
[ __ ] goddamn it get back here no
you're not getting away from me whatever
you are oh stop it
oh stop it you're so weird uh what is it
I don't like the fact that it has
spindly arms you stay there don't roll
it oh [ __ ] me oh god damn it I'm out of
oxygen aren't I
good thing there's some more right here
aah gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
it's harder than I thought it would be
to navigate you got to have some sort of
like jet pack that you can make for
yourself to get out of here because
otherwise navigating this would be
impossible I mean not impossible I guess
anything's possible when you're able to
carve entire mountains out with your
freakin space gun I hope I have enough
oxygen to be able to get out of here
it's gonna be close it's gonna be real
close especially with this I have some
oxygen here why isn't it using it
because it just wasn't enough for a
stack of it you know what I'm gonna
cheat a little bit I think I can
skedaddle a bit by just dropping this
forward oh my god what is that are those
eyeballs or is at its ass so weird when
I ask that question one I didn't know
I'd have to ever have to ask that
question my life and number two it's
weird that I don't know the answer that
is I ball zords ass is this alive or
what is this I got it I got a prize mom
you happy with me you gonna put this on
the fridge right thanks mom
sorry actually Oh God I'm very sorry
actually I'm sorry I did this and me do
it's gonna put this on [ __ ] stop that
Jesus it's good all right okay all right
popping it on there we go I don't know
what he's doing go for it I guess
okay what the [ __ ] is this the [ __ ] was
there well is that research truck okay I
can make a truck now I make a truck the
winter mine battery generator one seat
solar panel nope can't make it there
anyway what's up Fergus I don't know
what it's talking about
right either way I'm gonna put I can
make some aluminum but I need to make a
smelter I know that uh I need to make
another one of these which means I need
to me I need to get more resin so I'm
gonna put some stuff in storage right
here hydrazine and malachite that goes
in so I've got the malachite in the
aluminum in storage there and I'm gonna
go out and try to find more resin and if
I'm not mistaken there's plenty of resin
over there so I need more resin to be
able to make another one of these things
which can make me another another
another thing to build another building
like I built the printer and I built the
researcher so I need to build another
building like that and I spy oxygen on
the horizon which is gonna be great
which means that I can go out and
explore and get whatever I need I need
compound I need resin I wonder if I just
dig straight down if I'd be able to find
everything that I need would I tap into
a cave system eventually like I imagined
I would right and if I had all the power
than I need them there's really no worry
or concern I would just have everything
am I not mistaken here compound thanks
thanks thanks thanks thank you thanks
thanks thanks ooh hello ooh pre-made
things yes please okay good
whoa did this crash here well how does
that things still have power that's
crazy
Oh pre-made aluminum hell yes copper
hell yes lithium hell yes all of those
things whoa and a one-seater I'm
assuming that is okay you know what I'm
gonna I'm gonna hold on to that because
this is a research thing so if I take
this and bring it back with me I should
be I don't know what that is - but
whatever that's it's cool but all but I
got to bring this back because I get
more research out of it so once I get
this research thing in the research pod
I should have some resin no I didn't get
any resin I'm an idiot
all right pop this in the old in the old
research facility here do we have enough
power no we don't because we don't have
any solar power because the Sun is
literally never out can the Sun actually
you know rise little boy oh there we go
thank you that's delightful I feel like
it's been night forever
okay so there's not enough power to be
able to do research at least not yet I
could add one of my solar panels there
but I'm not gonna do that while the Sun
is up I'm gonna take advantage of this
energetic fact and I'm gonna try to I'm
literally gonna try to carve down as
deep as I can just because I like
digging holes in the ground I just kind
of want to see what I can do as far as
getting down in the earth oh that's
right when I go down far enough there
won't be any solar power oh that's right
do I hear the wind blowing oh no oh no
oh no sprint sprint buddy Oh run run run
run run run run run do not die
hoo boy whoo baby whoo baby whoo baby
okay do I have enough time to put my
stuff on the storage rack maybe I do
quick about it be quick about it put it
put it I don't care just put it on put
it on oh boy I gotta get it and got to
get inside gotta get inside okay getting
inside getting inside now now now now
whoa boy not that day oh it's close okay
so we've made a lot of progress we've
gotten a lot of materials and we got an
idea for what we need to do in the
future but the only thing we don't have
is more resin and then we haven't
researched this thing but we're gonna
hold off this storm can I close can I
close the damn door like maybe it would
be smart not to be right in the way of
all the blasting you know I know you
want some fresh air while you're in
there but maybe it wouldn't be a
wouldn't be too bad of an idea good
thing we got the printer in our way but
either way that's all the time I got for
this episode hope you guys are enjoying
this because I certainly am this game is
delightful and amazing and I love it
and I haven't even scratched the surface
on it literally I have not I want to see
if there's a way to get the [ __ ] like to
a different location like if I can make
a vehicle or something like I should be
able to do all sorts of [ __ ] but not
just yet so thank you everybody so much
for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]